What's going on everyone? Happy New
Year. Welcome back to another video.
Today we're going to be answering
everything you asked about the IB by
rejection and London 50 strategy. Before
we get into the video today, this is
going to be the 2026 goal for myself as
well as the community. We're going to be
tracking all the payouts. I'm aiming for
180,000 personally. That'll be about
15,000 per month. As for the community,
we're just going to see how many we can
rack in. Uh we're a mixture of beginners
as well as people that are already
getting payouts. If you want to jump in
on that, click the link down in the
description.
By far the most asked question that I've
been getting, whether it's on Twitter or
YouTube, is the win rate. Most of the
comments are just like this one you see
here. I have access to this on NQU
doesn't work. Don't fall for this trap.
So, I'm just going to show my stats for
December. This is pretty much just
trading the IB and London 50. Now, I did
have maybe three or four trades during
Asia session on these accounts, so
subject to error there. Total P&L 2,196
for the month of December. 62% win rate.
If you're just taking a look at the win
rate, you're missing out on a whole slew
of things with trading. Profit factor
and your riskreward are arguably more
important than your win rate. The profit
factor stands for how much you make for
every dollar that you lose. You want
this to be positive. If it's not
positive, then you are not a profitable
trader. The next one, average win
compared to the average loss, otherwise
known as your riskreward.
That should be positive. Doesn't need to
be massively positive. You're not going
to get two three RR. That's not all that
common. As long as that is over one and
your win rate is over 55% you're going
to be a profitable trader. Now most of
the trades I take these are on my
tradeify accounts are 2 to 4 M and Q.
The average trade length you can see
average trade duration 12 minutes 3
seconds 14 minutes 7 seconds for the
average win 8 minutes 41 seconds for the
average loss.
Positive RR trade direction not really
that directional. I do long slightly
more
slightly more often for these trades.
They're pretty much all 10:25 to 11:00,
12:00, depends on when the IB breaks or
the London 50 has a formation on the
15minute.
Most of my trades are going to be around
that 15-minut time frame because I trade
on the 15-minute chart. Now, going back
up to that profit factor and your
risk-reward, you can trade off a
negative riskreward for a much higher
percent win rate. Now, again, this is
just for the month of December. December
was pretty rough for price action. It
was pretty difficult, especially the
last two weeks on the IB strategy, but a
62% win rate with a 1.07 RR on average.
And the profit factor tells you all you
need to see. 1.74, meaning that every
dollar that I lose, I make a $1.74 back.
Do not focus in on the win rate. You're
missing out on the riskreward. If you
have a higher riskreward, you can have a
much lower win rate. I've seen people
that have 32 to 35% win rates, but they
have a two to three riskreward. And vice
versa, I've seen people like Trader Ike
on social media. If you haven't seen
him, go check him out.
He has probably a 6 to 7 riskreward,
meaning that he has a negative
riskreward, but his win rate is up in
the 85 to 90 percentile. The next most
asked question has to do with timing.
This also ties in with the win rate. So,
I'm going to explain what the IB as well
as the IB50 entry model is, as well as
going over the London 50 real quick,
maybe even cover a few previous day
entries.
To start off, the initial balance by
rejection strategy has about a 73% win
rate or a 73% chance of happening on any
given day depending on which high or low
is formed first. Again, that is what
level you're targeting. The IB50 is not
a stat on edgeful. They did just add it
recently, but it doesn't have any data
quite yet.
The stat itself is my own discovery. So
the IB straight, the IB by rejection,
you're looking for either a break of the
low or a break of the high depending on
whether the high or the low is formed
first. Wednesday, December 31st, great
example. We had the high form first
right at open and then we had the low
form at 10:15.
As you can see, we never got back to
IB50.
That's the best entry mile there is for
the strategy.
But you can take the trade without it
running to 50%.
All that does for you is it skews what
your riskreward is. So if I want to take
a short, let's say I enter right at
10:30, I'm targeting the IV low
and my stop loss. Really put it wherever
you want. You can put it just above the
IB50.
Realistically, the invalidation for the
strategy is going to be a break of the
IBI. So, that's a negative riskreward.
You're getting two risk for one reward.
Ideally, you get a retracement up to
50%. If you're just looking for 50%, you
missed Wednesday. I missed Wednesday. I
didn't take it. I wasn't really trading
on any funded accounts. I was just
trading on some EBELs.
Tuesday was a great example of how it
skews in the opposing direction, meaning
that you get a much better riskreward.
Tuesday, it's a little difficult to see,
but you just have to take my word for
it. We formed the low first and then on
that same 9:45 10:00 candle, we formed
the high. Given the stats, I the low
formed first. 73% chance that we go and
take the high. This is over six months,
by the way.
go back over to this chart and you can
see we went a whole lot lower than 50%
of the IB.
Again, I did not take this because I got
a little emotions. I had a human emotion
added into the trade. I thought for sure
we were going to go down and take the
low.
However,
we ended up pivoting all the way back up
and taking the IB high and then ended up
taking a double break in the IB for that
day as well. But what this does, and as
we just covered on this Wednesday's
trade, you were in for two risk, one
reward.
The day before Tuesday, if we had taken
that long position right at that 10:30
close, we had a four reward or a 4R,
4.6R on that trade, meaning that for one
risk, we're expecting a reward of 4.68.
And that's exactly what happened. You
don't always need to enter at 50% of the
IB. What you should do, and what I've
been doing with the strategy for the
past six months to seven months, is just
targeting the high or the low break. You
don't need to always enter at 50%. Some
days you're going to miss the entry.
Some days you're going to get the entry.
Uh Monday, December 29th, this was a
great example of that IB50 working out
perfectly. I entered right at 50% or
just below. And then I re-entered. I I
got another entry or added into the
position at 62125.
Ended up getting out for a 70 point gain
on the drop that happened on the 1045
candle. So I did not hold it for the
full continuation to the IV low. But
again, that is telling you that since
the high formed first, we're targeting
the IV low first break. IV low right
there.
It's telling you that about three out of
four days this strategy should work.
Now, I know in the last video I covered
trying to enter at 50% of the IB. The
reason being it just helps your
riskreward. You don't always need to
enter at 50%. You should be targeting
either the high or the low. Most days
you get a retracement
before 10:30. So, I want to add that in
as well to the timing question. I'll go
back here real quick. Uh, most of these
questions were, I entered right at
10:30. I entered after 10:30. When do
you enter? When do you enter?
I frontr run it up to 7 minutes. So, I
will enter this trade at 10:23 or later.
I will enter all the way up to 10:30,
sometimes even after 10:30.
And then I'm looking for whatever stat
is expected to break. Now again,
sometimes I enter it at 25% retracement,
meaning that my riskreward is 1:3 or 1
to four even. Sometimes I enter it all
the way down here where my riskreward
will be one risk for four reward.
Obviously, I didn't take that as I just
said on Monday, but it would have worked
out perfectly.
This strategy isn't as mechanical as it
may sound or it may be played out to be.
There are some other influences and uh
factors that go into the strategy. So
Tuesday, another reason that you might
have lost on this Tuesday, as we can
see, December 23rd, we formed the high
first, meaning that we should have
targeted the low breaking and then we
ended up going and taking the IV high.
It would have just been a a loss.
had we not also factored in that spy, if
we go and look at Tuesday,
SPY did not go and take a new IB low.
So, this is the same trading day right
here. This is something that I missed
and I did end up taking a loss on
Tuesday.
These two need to line up. SPY and Q's
need to line up or else you're going to
have divergence on the charts. One of
them is going to be a winner, one of
them is going to be a loser. In this
case, Q's ended up losing. SPY dragged
it up and continued to push up. Q's even
though stats were telling us that we
should have gone and taken the IV low
ended up being a 20% trade or a one in5
outcome.
For anyone that might be questioning the
win rate on it or wondering why I might
not have been as successful as it made
out to be in the video,
add confluences to the strategy. So the
IB by rejection, the IB50 entering the
IB, that alone should be a 73% win rate,
you're going to lose one out of four
trades on it. Sometimes you're going to
go in streaks of losing like December,
that wasn't a very good month to take
the IB trades, but over the past six
months, this is what the strategy has
yielded.
What you can add in is the London 50,
which we did get some questions on this
in the last video as well. London 50
adds several entry confluences to your
strategy. You can do it on SPY. You can
do it on QQQ. As you can see, SPY
Tuesday, December 23rd. If I was
targeting a continuation lower, I could
have slapped the London 50 on and been
Hey, we might get a continuation higher
off this actually because we just hit
London 50. London 50. For those that
don't know, even for those of you that
do know, the London 50 is any high or
low made during pre-market session for
New York. I know it's not the actual
London session, but I just gave it the
name London 50. So 4:00 a.m. to that
9:15m minute candle or the 9:30 open.
Any high or low made in that time frame,
you mark the high, mark the low using
the gone box or fib retracement,
whatever you want to use to get 50%.
Mark out 50% and then look for entries
off of that London 50. And then you also
slap that on with the initial balance
and that doubles your confluence. It
should add an additional win rate to
your trading strategy. In this case, it
would have worked out perfectly for
Tuesday. And then you can do the same
thing with previous days 50. Previous
days 50 is the range 4 a.m. to that 8:00
PM close. That's EST. Any high or low
made in that time frame for Monday,
December 22nd, our low was made right at
4 a.m. And our high was made looks like
at
12:45. Drag that out to the right. And
you can take entries off previous days
50 premarket. You can take entries off
previous day's high or previous day's
low. I like to take sweep entries,
meaning that the candle sweeps over
previous day's high or previous day's
low, and then look for the candle to
either make a wick and close under. This
is on the 15-minute time frame, or look
for the candle to just have a
continuation.
The next most asked question on all of
my trading strategies, all my videos,
pretty much every tweet that I have on
X, passing accounts. How long does it
take? How do I do it? Am I aiming for
$50 a day? Am I aiming for $140 a day?
It's dependent on
what you're offered in the market. It's
also dependent on your financial
situation. If you're able to size up
more than you should on eval because
you're trying to pass them faster,
that's your strategy. What I aim for is
passing the accounts in less than a
month. For Lucid, and this is why I
recommend Lucid for everyone, Lucid
Trading has a one-time payment. 25K
account, 50K account, whatever account
you get, whether it's the Flex, the Pro,
Instant Funded, it's a one-time payment.
So, you have absolutely no rush in
passing the account. For Apex accounts,
I got the recent promotion at 90% off,
so I was just aiming to pass them in
less than a month. I trade a little
riskier on them than I should have. It's
the same strategy that I'm taking every
day, though.
Instead of trading one to 2 MNQ, which I
would do on a funded, I trade two, maybe
even all the way up to six or even 8
MNQ.
The reason being, I'm just pushing to
get to the funded account. Now, if
you're in a weaker financial situation,
go over to Lucid. It's a onetime payment
and pass the account when you pass it.
There's absolutely no rush in passing
the account. Even if you're not in a
weak financial financial situation,
I still say pass the account when you
pass it. There's no reason to go in
rush. There's no reason to size up. Copy
trade over those accounts the same that
you would on a funded.
Pass them when you pass them.
Another commonly asked question I I did
miss some screenshots here is copy
trading. What do I do for copy trading
on the accounts?
The first platform that I use is project
X. I use this on both tradeify and
Lucid. You go over to project X. You go
to settings coffee trading and these are
how you highlight your accounts. You
have one leader account, four followers
for trade of eight, and these are where
I trade the Apex accounts. You go over
into the top right application settings,
go into add-ons,
scroll all the way down to group trade,
and this is free with Apex. I haven't
used it with take profit trader quite
yet. This should be free. I use the
built-in free copy trading platforms on
both Trade of Project X. I don't use
Trade Syncer. I probably will
eventually, but for now, I just have two
different tabs open. That's it.
Lastly, and again, I did miss some
screenshots on this question. Charting.
Why do I chart on QQQ as opposed to
charting on M and Q and NQ?
Now there might not be any exact
explanation for this. This is just how I
discovered most of the strategies that I
use.
The main reason that I use QQQ to chart
it's universal. MNQ and NQ sometimes if
you go on these charts they have
slippage. MNQ doesn't look like QQQ. MNQ
doesn't look like NQ. The same can be
said if you're going over to chart MGC
or if you're going over to chart gold.
Sometimes the charts don't look the
same. Now, they should look the same,
but what I mean by this, and I'm sure if
you've been trading long enough, you
know exactly what I'm talking about. M&Q
might have made a slight slightly higher
wick than NQ. And the same can be said
for going over to QQQ.
The reason that I use Q's is because it
simplifies everything down. It's what I
found and what I've always charted on
for the London 50.
It keeps it nice and simple with that
4:00 a.m. to 9:30 open. That's
pre-market as well as after hours is
4:00 to 8:00 PM EST. If I go over and
chart on MNQ, there's not really any
break in time frames. The only one that
is active on the chart is going to be
your 800 PM open or your 6 PM open
depending on where you are for GOPEX as
well as your 500 p.m. or 5:30 p.m.
close.
Otherwise, this chart trades 24 hours or
22 hours a day. Charting on QQQ, it just
simplifies everything down. I do the
same thing on gold as well. Instead of
trading or charting on GLD, excuse me,
instead of charting on GC, I chart on
GLD. It's the same thing. And if you
didn't know, SPY is the same as ES. QQQ
is the same as MNQ or an NQ.
GLD same as GC.
And then RTY,
that is the same as IWM. So, I just go
and chart on these. I think there's less
slippage. there's less room for error on
the charts. Just simplifies everything
down.
And that's it. If you guys didn't get
your question answered, drop it in the
comments and I will try to answer each
and every one. Something that I would
like to add on to the video is making
sure that you have a data provider.
And I am partnered with Edgeful, so
there might be a little bias here, but
this has removed
a significant amount of emotion as well
as just failure in general from my
trading. This adds an additional
confluence on to everything that I
trade. Every single morning, I come in
here, I look at the gap fill by size.
This tells me the chance that we're
going to have a gap fill for the day.
So, if we're trending up or down
pre-market, this tells me, am I going to
be stupid and try to reverse it or am I
going to look for a continuation? The
next thing that I go and do is look at
inside bars. And this is probably one of
the better reports on Edgeville. Tells
you whether or not we're going to break
out of the previous day's range or if
we're going to stay within it. If price
opens outside of previous day's range,
the stat does not apply. the price opens
inside of previous day's range, then
that gives a pretty significant draw to
previous day's high or previous days
low. Just something to add into your
trading strategy, I'll drop the link for
them in the description as well.
Lastly, if you guys did enjoy the video
and you want to become a part of the
community, I'm going to drop that in the
description as well. We're going to be
aiming for pretty much just an infinite
amount of payouts this year. See how
much we can get to in 2026. Personal
amount for me is going to be 15,000 a
month or 180,000 for the end of the
year. If you guys enjoyed the video,
thank you for sticking around this long.
Drop a like, subscribe. I'll see you
next week for another video.